if there remained any lingering optimism
that the world is too interconnected for
large capitalist nations to go to war
february 24th 2022 was the final nail in
the coffin
the russian invasion of ukraine is far
from the first armed conflict this
century
nor is it even the first initiated by
russia
but in its scale and proximity to the
european continent it's perhaps the most
symbolically significant
clearly the golden arches theory of
history which suggests no two countries
home to a mcdonald's franchise will
fight one another fails to capture the
senseless violence some leaders are
capable of inflicting
but although we aren't living in the end
of history neither could any simple
economic model predict the scale or
speed of the corporate exodus from
russia
the same companies which lend only lip
service to climate change many of which
had not millions but billions invested
in the country
simply packed up and left and all in the
span of a few weeks
when mcdonald's announced its complete
exit from the russian market 81 days
after the war began we learned another
important lesson
not only is globalization not inevitable
but it can all unravel in an instant
and you can bet that if these largely
self-imposed corporate sanctions
surprised us
they absolutely shocked china where
everything is pure business
everyone everywhere is now quietly
wondering
if russia the world's 11th largest
economy could be effectively isolated
overnight could the same thing happen to
china
sponsored by curiosity stream and nebula
where you can watch the now released
third episode of my original series
this one is about china's dominance of
rare earth elements the essential
ingredients for everything from
smartphones to guided missiles
we talk about how china came to
monopolize their production and whether
or not the us should be worried
with the 15 a year curiosity stream and
nebula bundle you get access to the
entire exclusive series which is now an
hour long and covers how chinese
censorship actually works along with why
it won't abandon covet xero anytime soon
if you enjoy these videos sign up now to
essentially get 50 percent more of them
china is not russia
placing the latter's 1.4 trillion gdp
next to china's helps put things in
perspective the russian economy is 10
times smaller
you could merge it in fact with the
korean brazilian australian spanish
mexican canadian italian and french
economies and it would still be smaller
perhaps more importantly russia is
insulated
its largest export market is china which
buys 13 of its goods
and of its top eight buyers half could
be characterized as if not an ally at
least somewhat friendly
just about five percent of its imports
came from the united states
over one-fifth from china and in third
place is belarus
now compare that with china's top export
destinations
the first thing you'll notice is that a
whole one-sixth goes to just one country
the u.s
and in reality that number is likely
much larger because second place is hong
kong where many chinese goods are
re-exported abroad
immediately below hong kong are non-nato
american allies japan and south korea
and slightly lower nato allies germany
the netherlands and the uk
china in other words is much more
dependent on america and her allies
but trade in aggregate is a very crude
proxy for how much two countries depend
on one another
for one what is being traded matters a
lot
to spell out the obvious the current
flow of goods is driven almost entirely
by cost and costs are based on the
current circumstances
if those circumstances changed most
trade wouldn't disappear it would simply
be reorganized and rerouted
take australia for example
the country produces a large quantity of
iron coal and beef of which china is by
far its largest customer
in 2000 just five percent of australian
exports went to china
by 2020 that number had increased
six-fold
so dependent on its northern neighbor is
australia that it has often been
described only partly humorously as a
chinese satellite state
clearly believing this narrative china
tried to bully what it perceived as
small easy prey in 2020 over what it
called 14 grievances which include
australia's call for an investigation
into the origins of covet 19.
what followed was nothing short of a
full-blown trade war
china imposed tariffs duties and bans
not to mention a state-organized boycott
of australian imports
but beijing overplayed its hand while
the trade disruption wasn't without
costs australia turned around and found
new buyers
first china began looking for new
sellers to replace australia
those turned out to be russia and
indonesia
russia and indonesia previously supplied
india japan and south korea who were
likewise now in need of a new supplier
as you can see here their new supplier
was australia
think of trade like a city's road
network
sure you can block off one street but
traffic will simply find a new route
any disruption will ripple throughout
the city causing some congestion but a
new equilibrium will eventually be found
bans tariffs trade wars and sanctions
therefore aren't necessarily as
catastrophic as they may seem
it all depends on what is being traded
australia was selling iron coal and beef
high demand commodities for which there
are many possible buyers
likewise although oil iron soybeans and
copper are among china's largest imports
by value we can safely assume it will
always have access to a seller
and not just because these are
commodities
in the wake of u.s sanctions against
russia many were surprised by the degree
of international cooperation
even historically neutral countries like
switzerland and singapore proactively
complied and publicly denounced the war
if china were to say seize and occupy an
outlying taiwanese island it would
prompt similar reflection from fence
sitters like singapore
but getting everyone to cooperate with
the toughest kind of sanctions against
china would be a much more difficult
challenge
iron soybeans and oil would likely keep
flowing from brazil for example
the country simply has too much to lose
if push came to shove china could roll
back some of its environmental
regulations allowing it to more easily
source dirty commodities like coal
domestically
the catch
everything would be more expensive
a lot more expensive
no country has benefited more from the
us navy's guarding of the world shipping
lanes than china
if it were ever to withdraw that
protection china would enter a world of
hurt
but that's the easy stuff
the real challenge would be advanced
technology
you don't have to take my word for it
either
china has assembled what is effectively
a list of its own weaknesses
technologies and components it wants to
be able to produce domestically
despite investing many tens of billions
of dollars into commercial airplane
manufacturing for example china is
almost entirely dependent on foreign
imports
its most commercially viable domestic
plane the c919 still requires parts from
ge an american company
tellingly no one outside of china buys
it
if the u.s ever applied maximum
sanctions chinese commercial aviation
would simply crash and burn though its
fast network of high-speed rail would
somewhat soften the blow
at the very least the industry would be
forced to regress something like 40
years
but even this hypothetical bloodbath
pales in comparison to semiconductors
there's a reason they receive so much
air time and discussions about china the
country buys a ton of them
in purely dollar terms it imports as
many semiconductors as it does crude oil
and that's saying a lot china buys
one-fourth of the entire world's oil by
value
even after investing 22 billion dollars
on a national semiconductor fund in 2014
and plenty more since the truth is that
china remains years behind
what it produces are almost exclusively
low to medium end ships
if cut off from imports it'd still be
able to make things like microwaves and
televisions but not iphone 13s
it's not that china is behind and
catching up
in terms of trade it's behind and
actively losing ground
here you can see its semiconductor
deficit not shrinking but growing over
time
and quite dramatically
nine women can't make a baby in a month
and money alone can't instantly manifest
an advanced semiconductor industry
because china has been deliberately
blocked from access to crucial
ingredients like the dutch lithography
machines required to make the smallest
chips the only path forward entails
billions of dollars of investment and
many years of patience
according to one estimate the country
has a shortage of 300 000 semiconductor
engineers
at the current rate of 30 000 new
workers entering the industry each year
it would take at least 10 years to catch
up to 2022 technology
and that's being optimistic
now in fairness some number of
semiconductors and other essential parts
could fall off a truck so to speak and
find their way to china even with
sanctions
researchers for instance recently
disassembled russian weapons used in
ukraine only to discover american and
european ships engines and other parts
shell companies and intermediaries can
covertly buy sanctioned parts
and given the state of consumer
electronics today enemy militaries can
even source parts from products sold at
walmart
but the fact remains
china is deeply dependent on western
imports
just look at the growing divide between
what it says and what it actually does
xi jinping's first overseas trip as
president was to moscow
and on february 4th this year just 20
days before the invasion of ukraine
putin was shi's first in-person meeting
with another head of state in over two
years
since then china has refused to condemn
the invasion or even refer to it as an
invasion
officially it quote does not participate
in sanctions against russia
but the reality is although it may do so
very quietly it does participate
no chinese bank no matter how patriotic
is willing to risk defying american
sanctions
likewise in 2021 china passed an
anti-sanctions law which essentially
makes it illegal for chinese nationals
to comply with american sanctions
against china
make no mistake this law is driven not
by supreme confidence but rather
deep-seated fear
if sanctions were nothing to worry about
it wouldn't be necessary
its purpose is to increase the cost of
sanctions thereby in theory making them
less likely
but this reluctance goes both ways
that divide between saying and doing is
also quite large in america
trade is of course a two-way street
chinese imports mean dollars in the bank
for american companies
not to mention that many chinese imports
are then assembled into final products
and shipped to the states
this is a list of companies on the smp
with the highest percentage of sales in
china
with the sole exception of wynn resorts
which operates casinos in macau
nine of the top 10 are suppliers of
semiconductors or other advanced
technology components
not far behind with one fourth of its
revenue coming from china is the second
largest public company on earth by
market cap apple
if the american semiconductor industry
were cut off completely from china it
would lose at least 80 billion dollars
and 125 000 jobs according to the
commerce department
beyond lost sales these companies rely
on china to reach their economies of
scale
if they lost half their unit sales you
can expect they'd be less than half as
competitive therefore globally
such an extreme move would mean the end
of u.s dominance over the highest of
high tech
taken as a whole american companies have
around 400 billion dollars at risk in
china
decoupling as it's often called would
lower american gdp by an estimated two
percent
chinese companies by comparison only
generate about a third as much revenue
within the united states
the us-china relationship is really
unlike any other
inevitably each will move toward greater
independence
already some american companies are
diversifying their supply chains
huawei zte and officials in hong kong
have likewise already been sanctioned
but however much leaders in each country
may deny this fact decoupling will be a
slow and difficult process and almost
certainly never be complete
the most extreme form of sanctions would
require a total trade blockade which is
itself an act of war
to seize china's foreign exchange like
the us did to russia would be no less
unthinkable
indeed even russia is granted exceptions
to export fertilizer to the world and
oil to europe
there is however one trump card we
haven't discussed
china controls access to the vast
majority of what are called rare earth
elements the ingredients required to
produce almost any piece of modern
technology from smartphones to f-35s
in 1992 deng xiaoping proclaimed quote
the middle east has oil china has rare
earths
that's the subject of the new 17-minute
third episode of our new nebula original
series china actually
sign up now and you'll also get access
to the first two episodes
the first is about how chinese
censorship actually works and why there
are protests in china
the second is about the real reason
china refuses to allow even a single
case of coronavirus and why it likely
won't fully open its borders anytime
soon
altogether that's an hour of exclusive
polymatter content you'll also get
access to future videos in the series
plus you get ad-free and early access to
all polymatter videos
and other original series on nebula not
to mention access to curiosity stream
home to great full-length documentaries
on science technology and history
after i finish recording this video for
example i'm gonna watch this one about
how container ships work
get all that for just 15 a year right
now with the nebula and curiosity stream
bundle
click or tap the link on screen right
now or in the description